la presencia de al-qaida en afganistán y
la planificación de los ataques contra
nueva york y washington
paso gracias a su presencia en
afganistán ahí gracias a la protección
del régimen de los talibán
en 2001 y
las relaciones y la cooperación entre
los talibanes y al qaida sigue hasta hoy
con una presencia con unas relaciones
con cooperación y con el peligro ahora
que de nuevo hay un territorio que le
pueda dar refugio y una base logística
para planear ataques y organizarse si
también difundir la ideología que
justifica la violencia contra 200 mire
la responsabilidad de apoyar a las
víctimas del terrorismo recae en los
estados miembros de las naciones unidas
pero en la práctica cuál es su alcance
el secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres le dijo que la comunidad
internacional debe unirse para
asegurarse de que afganistán nunca más
se utilice como plataforma para
organizaciones terroristas sin embargo
las sensaciones de impotencia ante las
noticias de mujeres atacadas por el
talibán de colaboradores de eeuu y otras
potencias asediados por los extremistas
sin duda las palabras de secretarios son
muy lindas pero son son palabras el
único medio que logro
a degradar el poder la capacidad letal
de organizaciones como al qaeda fue la
intervención militar de eeuu y de sus
aliados de la otan en 2001-2002 y sólo
siguiendo con una pelea muy fuerte y
contundente contra estas organizaciones
que debe continuar en todo el mundo
claramente con la cooperación
internacional se puede lograr el
objetivo de contener y limitar la fuerza
letal de estas organizaciones el
problema claramente y lo vemos en estos
días en afganistán es que atrás del
terrorismo hay
ideologías que justifican la violencia
como medio para lograr objetivos
políticos revolucionarios y hay estados
y ofrecen la protección el apoyo y
también la financiación del terrorismo y
el problema entonces no es solamente
de las ideologías sedados de los
movimientos pero también de los estados
miembros de la comunidad internacional
que contra la ley internacional siguen
apoyando al terrorismo y permitiéndoles
de operar en muchos lugares y muy
rápidamente dejando un poco la situación
de afganistán en qué partes del mundo se
concentran las víctimas de terrorismo
hoy
bueno el problema de que el terrorismo
es un fenómeno global la gran mayoría de
las víctimas del terrorismo islamista
del cual a al qaida y los talibanes
hacen parte son musulmanes porque el
terrorismo islamista de estas
organizaciones
empieza peleando y golpeando contra sus
sociedades pero como sabemos hay también
víctimas y ayer hubieron casos muy
trágicos de terrorismo en el otro
lugares incluido en latinoamérica con
matriz ideológica de bario tipo como
islamista y también de los cárteles o de
ideología marxista